declaraciones de homenaje y mensajes de
condolencias twitter fue el espacio en
el que varios jefes de estado y líderes
mundiales usaron para expresar su
sentido pésame por el asesinato del ex
primer ministro de japón sin suave con
sus mensajes en japonés muchos lo
llamaron amigo y visionario y aseguraron
que era un gran líder para la esfera
internacional
nos gustaría expresar nuestras
condolencias al gobierno de japón y al
pueblo japonés en nombre del pueblo
francés japón ha perdido a un gran
primer ministro que dedicó su vida al
país y trató de equilibrar el mundo
japón es un aliado muy estable de eeuu y
todavía no sé si esto va a tener algún
impacto profundo que se estabilice la
seguridad o la solidaridad de japón
desde bali indonesia el canciller ruso
aseguró ser el único que se refirió a la
muerte de ave en la reunión del g20
acabo de hacer el comentario de que fui
el único en la reunión que expresó sus
condolencias a la parte japonesa a
través del ministro pero minutos después
la ministra de asuntos exteriores de
australia un país muy cercano a japón
elogió el legado de ave y su
contribución a la sociedad que han
creado a ambos países seguido de un tuit
por parte de la premier de nueva zelanda
otro país aliado del gobierno nipón
el señor ave fue el más cercano de los
amigos de australia condenamos este
espantoso acto de violencia
su muerte es trágica es una noticia
devastadora para japón y su pueblo
rivero fue uno de los primeros líderes
que conocí cuando me convertí en primera
ministra estaba profundamente
comprometido con su papel pero también
era generoso y amable
la policía detuvo al pistolero un hombre
de 41 años ex integrante de la marina de
japón quien con una arma casera disparó
la bala que le quitó la vida al primer
ministro que más tiempo estuvo en el
cargo en la historia del país